" Les droits fondamentaux,
c'est sur les trottoirs
du boulevard de la Villette.
Je mènerai campagne
pour vous stigmatiser
et pour vous dire que vous
n'êtes ni la République, ni la France ! "
9 fois sur 10, quand vous voyez
sur votre petit écran
quelque chose d'important
qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée,
vraiment c'est LCP d'abord
qui l'a repéré
et là où on est fiers, c'est quand
on a travaillé jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et qu'au petit matin on se réveille
avec dans les matinales radio ou télé
l'extrait fort de l'Assemblée.
Parmi les plus gros cartons
de la chaîne sur internet,
c'est la commission d'enquête
sur le coronavirus.
" Mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce pays infantilisé ?
Il faut quand même un peu
se prendre en main dans ce pays !
C'est ça la leçon
qu'il faut tirer. "
On a eu des chiffres historiques sur l'audition
bien sûr du professeur Didier Raoult.
" Et c'est vrai, je suis un grand scientifique.
Je sais ce qui est un essai
et je peux vous dire qu'il y a
une dizaine de traitements que j'ai inventés
qui sont dans tous les livres
de référence médicaux.
Et celui-là y sera aussi ! "
On twitte tout, mais on ne va jamais
se contenter de juste twitter à la surface.
On va aussi essayer
d'aller toujours au fond du débat.
Et en prenant bien sûr
un peu de chaque côté de l'hémicycle
pour avoir
toutes les opinions.
" Retirez s'il vous plaît ce gilet.
Monsieur Lassalle ! "
La vidéo de Jean Lassalle, c'est une vidéo
qui a dépassé le million de vues le jour-même.
" Monsieur Lassalle, s'il vous plaît,
allez manifester hors de cet hémicycle !
S'il vous plaît. "
Même si bien sûr c'était un coup
politique de la part de Jean Lassalle,
c'était aussi révélateur
de quelque chose de plus profond,
qui fait qu'une grande crise
allait s'annoncer
et s'était matérialisée par
un gilet jaune sur 577 députés.
" La séance est suspendue ! "
Il y a aussi des débats économiques
qui ont été très suivis,
comme la privatisation
d'Aéroports de Paris,
dans le cadre de la loi PACTE.
" Ayez le courage de donner
la parole à 44 millions d'électeurs,
aux Français, qui sont
les propriétaires de la Française des jeux,
qui sont les propriétaires
d'aéroports de Paris ! "
Sur internet, on a tout
le temps qu'on veut. Voilà.
On peut aussi bien faire une vidéo
de 10 secondes d'une phrase forte
qu'un débat qui dure 8 heures.
Et ça, c'est vrai que
sur nos réseaux,
quand on est passionné
de politique,
citoyen un peu curieux
ou qu'on a juste envie de
se tenir informé des débats du pays
en suivant LCP, on est sûr de
trouver notre compte.